476, le dernier empereur
d'Occident romain, Romulus Augustule,
est dépossédé de son titre
par Odoacre, le chef d'une troupe barbare
dont l'ethnie est inconnue.
L'Empire est alors officiellement ouvert
à tous les vents et à tous les barbares.
Les Mérovingiens doivent
leur nom à Mérovée, Mérovée qui est,
l'ancêtre un petit peu mythique.
dit-on de Clovis.
La tribu des Mérovingiens,
qui sont des Francs saliens, des Germains,
des germaniques vont régner
sur ce qui deviendra l'Allemagne,
la Belgique, la France et la Suisse
du Vᵉ au VIIIᵉ siècle.
C'est en 481 que l'on date
le début du règne de Clovis.
Grégoire, évêque de Tours de 573 à 594,
compila pendant ses années d'épiscopat
l'histoire des Francs.
Il décrit son règne
comme celui d'un visionnaire
inspiré par Dieu.
C'est notamment grâce à lui
que des générations d'écoliers français
se sont vu conter
le récit du vase de Soissons,
celui des batailles de Tolbiac
et de Vouillé, celui du baptême de Reims.
Tous ces récits fourniront
un support inépuisable
à l'imagerie d'Épinal
et à l'imagination populaire,
mais sont autant de pièces d'un puzzle
que nous allons essayer de reconstituer.
Les Francs font leur apparition
dans l'histoire dans les années 256-260.
Hors de l'Empire, entre Rhin
et Danube, ce sont des Germains.
Ils sont certainement nés
d'une mosaïque complexe de tribus
qui avaient pris
l'habitude de piller pour vivre
et qui finissent par s'unir dans le cadre
d'une confédération guerrière
pour survivre.
Les Francs vont participer
en Gaule du Nord
à la rencontre
entre Romains et Germains.
L'empire romain,
après une vague d'invasions
au IIIᵉ siècle,
avait réussi à reconstituer son unité.
Mais au début du Vᵉ siècle,
en 406, une nouvelle invasion brise
la frontière nord de l'Empire
et de nombreux peuples s'engouffrent
dans la brèche, notamment
les Francs, qui sont tantôt des ennemis,
mais le plus souvent des alliés
de Rome qui servent à repousser
les autres peuples barbares.
Depuis le milieu du IIIᵉ siècle,
c'est la fin de la Pax Romana,
paix romaine.
La menace barbare pousse l'Empire
à faire ses premières concessions,
en particulier en Gaule.
l'Empire consent à signer
des traités appelés fœdus avec eux,
leur versant un tribut en échange
de contingents de soldats dits fédérés.
La plupart des peuples
barbares sont bien intégrés.
Ce sont des peuples
qui sont alliés de Rome,
souvent depuis pratiquement un siècle,
et qui reçoivent le statut de fédérés,
c'est-à-dire d'alliés de Rome.
Ils reçoivent des territoires administrés,
des ressources à exploiter,
essentiellement des terres,
et sont des alliés de Rome,
au point que lorsque
les rois barbares frappent monnaie,
ce n'est pas leur
effigie qu'ils mettent sur la monnaie,
mais celle de l'empereur romain.
Premier pilier de la Pax Romana,
l'armée est infiltrée
par des éléments barbares
de plus en plus
nombreux chaque année.
Mais ce n'est pas tout.
Le tribut accordé n'est pas
seulement une somme d'argent,
c'est une terre
ou une part des revenus fiscaux.
Les barbares sont intégrés
au système économique de l'Empire.
Les trois principaux peuples barbares
installés au Vᵉ siècle en Gaule,
sont des peuples fédérés.
Les Wisigoths au Sud-Ouest
ont été les premiers en Gaule dès 418.
Les Burgondes au Sud-Est
et les Francs au nord suivirent.
La population franc
se divisait en deux groupes
les Francs Rhénans et les Francs Saliens.
Si le premier groupe allait rapidement
disparaître au profit du second,
ce dernier allait être à l'origine
d'une des plus grandes aventures
de l'histoire de l'humanité.
Parmi les nombreux
peuples qui constituent les Francs,
il y a une unité importante
qui est l'unité salienne.
Ils fournissent
des contingents nombreux
à l'armée romaine, contingents
essentiellement de mercenaires.
Il semble qu'ils constituent
le groupe dominant entre les Francs,
alors que les Francs rhénans
constituent les Francs indigènes,
c'est-à-dire ceux qui n'ont pas quitté
la Germanie primitive.
Les Francs rhénans
n'ont pas conclu de fœdus avec l'Empire.
Ils sont installés hors
des frontières à l'est du Rhin,
se contentant
d'incursions au cours du Vᵉ siècle.
Ainsi, ils sont restés indépendants
alors que les Francs saliens
étaient depuis la fin du IVᵉ siècle
installés par fœdus, au sud
des Pays-Bas et dans la Belgique actuelle.
Leur nom vient probablement
de Salans, région du nord des Pays-Bas.
Leur premier roi connu
est Clodion le Chevelu.
On ne sait si Clodion partageait
le pouvoir avec d'autres rois saliens,
comme c'était de tradition,
ou si occasionnellement
il avait pu rassembler ce pouvoir.
Quoi qu'il en soit,
c'est sous son impulsion
que dans la première moitié du Vᵉ siècle,
les Francs saliens sortent de leurs marais
et s'emparent
de Tournai et de Cambrai.
Contrairement aux habitudes
des guerriers germains,
les villes ne sont pas pillées.
Clodion est ensuite arrêté
dans sa progression par l'armée romaine.
Plus que la paix, il obtient par fœdus
en 431 les territoires qu'il a conquis.
Les fœdus avec les Germains sont d'autant
plus facilement consentis par l'Empire
qu'il y a plus barbare que ces barbares.
Les hordes du cruel Attila.
Attila est le célèbre chef
des huns, un personnage selon la légende
absolument terrible,
chef de cette tribu de turco mongols
qui va faire des ravages
considérables en Europe
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit anéanti
dans la bataille des champs catalauniques
par le général Aetius.
En 451,
les huns lancent un raid sur la Gaule.
Loyaux, les Francs saliens interviennent
pour sauver Rome
et pour contrer
la progression d'Attila,
le 20 juin 451, lors de la bataille
dite des champs catalauniques,
à la tête des troupes franques,
Mérovée, fils de Clodion.
On sait qu'au Vᵉ siècle, toute une série
de rois francs apparaissent
dans les sources, il est possible
qu'un certain Mérovée ait existé
ayant eu un pouvoir assez faible
dans la région de la Belgique actuelle.
Mérovée va donner son nom
à toute une dynastie de rois appelés
Mérovingiens parce que le groupe
auquel il appartenait, les Francs saliens,
allait marquer l'histoire
grâce à son petit-fils Clovis.
Le fils de Mérovée s'appelait Childéric.
Il était roi
des Francs saliens de Tournai.
Il portait au doigt,
jusque dans son tombeau,
un anneau marqué
d'un sceau Childirici regis.
L'Anneau d'or était le signe distinctif
de l'ordre équestre pour les Romains.
Cet ordre fournissait
à l'Empire ses officiers supérieurs.
Childéric était donc, considéré
par Rome comme un général romain.
Mais la sépulture contenait
aussi des armes et des bijoux,
dont un bracelet d'or massif,
marque de la royauté chez les Germains.
Cet homme d'1,80 m,
était représenté sur son anneau
avec les cheveux longs,
les cheveux longs tressés,
étaient le symbole
de force pour les Francs.
C'était l'assurance de la transmission
de père en fils du Mund,
la puissance magique du chef
qui lui permettait
de mener ses hommes à la victoire.
Le Mund est un devoir
de protection du roi sur son peuple,
mais également
de l'homme sur la femme.
Le Mund,
dans un contexte conjugal,
peut être transmis,
mais peut être également vendu.
Les Mérovingiens
dans la famille royale sont très à cheval
sur leur chevelure, parce que c'est
une réminiscence de la Bible, de Samson.
Tout simplement, ils considèrent
que la force, la puissance,
le respect est obtenu,
est acquis grâce à la chevelure.
Donc, ils portent tous
une merveilleuse crinière,
ce qui permet d'ailleurs
parfois à certains rois qui semaient
des petits bâtards à droite
et à gauche de les convoquer,
ou certains portant de longues crinières
de cheveux, disaient,
je suis un de vos fils,
il disait non, tu ne l'es pas.
Et il faisait tondre immédiatement.
On a d'ailleurs
de merveilleux rois qui ont été chevelus.
Childéric veut dire Hilderic
en vieux francique puissant à la guerre.
Ainsi, Childéric eut des
funérailles mi-romaines mi-barbares.
Auprès de Childéric,
on inhuma sa femme.
Ils eurent ensemble un fils
qui succéda à Childéric
dès l'âge de quinze ans.
Selon la loi
des Francs saliens, la loi salique,
le jeune franc était majeur
à douze ans et à quinze ans,
il pouvait porter
les armes et donc détenir le Mund.
Childéric légua à son fils, en même temps
que la puissance magique du chef,
un système de valeurs reposant
sur le vieux paganisme germanique,
leur religion antique.
Ce jeune roi s'appelait Clovis
ou Ludwig illustre au combat.
La capitale de Clovis se trouvait
alors à Tournai, au nord d'une Gaule
encore romaine
mais divisée, livrée à elle-même.
Entre la Somme,
la Meuse, la Loire et l'Armorique,
l'État romain se réduisait
comme peau de chagrin.
À la tête de ce résidu d'empire,
Syagrius exerçait les fonctions
de maître de la milice depuis 471.
Le quartier général
de Syagrius était installé
dans la cité de Soissons.
Ce dernier ne détenait pas de légitimité.
Il succédait à son père
qui commença à ne plus reconnaître
l'autorité de l'empire.
Le Mund, le prestige magique du chef
était contenu dans le nom de Clovis,
mais il devait être confirmé
sur le champ de bataille.
Les armes devaient parler.
L'affrontement
avec Syagrius était inévitable.
Il eut lieu en 486.
Clovis sollicita l'appui
des autres chefs saliens.
Chararic, installé à Thérouanne, refuse.
Ragnacaire installé à Cambrai
sur la route entre Tournai et Soissons
et donc sur la route de Clovis, accepte.
Vaincu, Syagrius est exécuté.
Toute victoire mérite butin.
Les églises sont alors ravagées.
Le chef de guerre
est le garant de la loi de la guerre.
Et cette loi exige
que le butin soit rassemblé
afin d'être équitablement
réparti entre les vainqueurs.
Or, Clovis a voulu
en soustraire un vase
avant même le début
de la distribution, un vase liturgique
que lui réclamait un évêque.
Parmi ce butin,
au moment du partage,
Clovis a entendu dire
que l'évêque de Reims,
Saint-Rémi, voudrait récupérer.
Mon Dieu, Clovis serait
gentil s'il voulait lui redonner
ce merveilleux vase
en argent qu'on a volé.
Alors Clovis répartit
le butin avec ses hommes
et dit "je prends ma part
et je vais prendre ce vase en plus".
Il demanda pour cela
la permission à ses guerriers.
L'un d'eux préféra briser
le vase d'un coup de francisque
plutôt que
d'enfreindre une loi ancestrale.
Dans la troupe,
un soldat jaillit avec sa francisque
et abat sa hache
sur le vase en disant,
"Tu n'auras que ce que
le sort voudra bien t'accorder".
Clovis ne réagit pas tout de suite.
Il attendit un an.
Il profita
d'une revue au Champ de Mars
au cours de laquelle
il réprimanda, le briseur de vases,
pour le mauvais état de ses armes.
Il jeta alors la francisque
du guerrier qui se baissa immédiatement
pour la ramasser.
Il lui dit
ton épée est mal entretenue,
ton arme commence
à rouiller et il sort lui, sa francisque.
et il tranche le col
du soldat en lui disant,
"Souviens-toi du vase de Soissons".
Ses hommes ont été
absolument impressionnés
et Clovis pouvait acquérir
le respect à ce moment-là,
sérieusement,
auprès de ses troupes.
Clovis fit raser la tête
de Chararic, l'un des chefs saliens,
ainsi que celle
de son fils, car Chararic avait refusé
de se joindre
à l'expédition de Soissons.
Chararic humilié,
son fils le consola
en lui promettant vengeance
une fois les cheveux repoussés.
Clovis les fit donc décapiter.
Clovis enfonça ensuite
une hache dans le crâne de Ragnacaire,
l'autre chef, qui lui, avait pourtant
répondu favorablement à son appel.
On peut penser que la victoire
de Soissons autorisait le charismatique
chef de guerre
à concentrer le pouvoir
et à devenir
le seul roi des Francs saliens.
Après les armes,
il y avait une autre manière de procéder
pour accroître
son influence, l'alliance matrimoniale.
Clovis avait utilisé
cette pratique au tout début de son règne
en contractant une union
avec une princesse du groupe royal
des francs rhénans.
Elle mourut assez
rapidement, mais eut le temps
d'engendrer un premier héritier, Thierry.
Maintenant établi à Soissons,
Clovis devait asseoir
son autorité nouvelle.
Plein Est se trouvaient les Alamans,
des païens peu romanisés.
Au Sud-Ouest, le royaume
des Wisigoths convertis au christianisme.
Au Sud-Est le royaume
des Burgondes, convertis eux aussi.
Cette conversion n'était
cependant pas complète.
Burgondes et Wisigoths étaient ariens.
L'arianisme, pour qui Jésus,
le Fils de Dieu, était une essence divine
et pas une incarnation divine,
ne correspondait pas
au dogme de l'Église catholique
qui fut redéfini
au concile de Nicée en 325.
Cependant,
cette conception plaisait au peuple
qui délaissait à peine le paganisme.
Elle faisait du Christ un sur-être,
comme le chef qui les menait au combat.
l'arianisme est
une hérésie qui est apparue
dans l'Empire
romain au IVᵉ siècle.
Dans la mesure où les barbares
du IVᵉ siècle se sont convertis
en masse à la religion romaine,
ils se convertirent à l'arianisme.
C'est une subordination
du Fils au Père au sein de la Trinité,
c'est-à-dire que les ariens considèrent
que la Trinité n'est pas formée
de trois personnes égales,
mais d'un père tout-puissant, d'un fils,
d'un Saint-Esprit légèrement inférieurs.
L'arianisme atteignit tous
les Barbares établis dans l'Empire,
sauf les Germains du Nord,
c'est-à-dire les Francs et les Alamans,
tandis que le clergé occidental
resta fondamentalement nicéen.
Des deux royaumes
ariens du sud de la Gaule,
l'un persécutait
les catholiques romains.
C'était le royaume des Wisigoths.
L'autre, le royaume des Burgondes,
avait adopté des lois tolérantes.
D'ailleurs, au sein de la famille royale,
il y avait déjà des catholiques.
Parce que c'était
la volonté de leur mère,
deux princesses Burgondes,
filles d'un roi défunt, avaient reçu
le saint sacrement du baptême.
L'une d'elles, Clotilde, était
très belle et parée de toutes les vertus.
L'occasion était belle
pour Clovis d'établir un rapprochement
avec le royaume burgonde
par un mariage avec Clotilde.
Il eut lieu en 493.
Le chef de guerre est un négociateur,
mais il reste un chef de guerre.
Et les alamans menaçaient
les positions des francs rhénans
dans le bassin de Cologne.
Face à ces autres païens,
en 496, à la bataille dite de Tolbiac,
alors que la situation commençait
à être désespérée,
Clovis fit le vœu de se convertir
si Jésus, que Clotilde proclame
fils du Dieu vivant,
lui donnait la victoire.
On attribue le nom
de Tolbiac à une bataille
qui se déroule à une date assez incertaine
entre les Francs de Clovis et les Alamans,
sans doute
dans la région du Rhin.
On ignore totalement
le lieu de cet événement.
Simplement, le nom est resté
célèbre parce qu'à la bataille de Tolbiac,
selon les récits de Grégoire
de Tours, Clovis aurait décidé
de se convertir au catholicisme.
La Gaule est encore romaine en 480.
Si elle se transforme,
c'est qu'elle est en train
de devenir chrétienne et de connaître
une véritable révolution mentale.
En 313, l'empereur romain Constantin
avait fait promulguer un édit à Milan.
Un édit de tolérance
accordé au christianisme,
qui marqua la fin
des persécutions contre les chrétiens.
Phénomène urbain
comme la romanisation,
la christianisation voit
ses premières communautés
se créer en Gaule dans les cités.
Or, le domaine des francs saliens
n'est que très peu urbanisé.
Dans les campagnes,
l'étymologie nous apprend
que le mot paysan vient de païen.
C'est tout dire.
Un soldat de l'armée romaine envoyé
en Gaule commença à faire parler de lui
un soir d'hiver,
en 338 à Amiens,
où, après avoir donné
toute sa solde à des indigents,
finit par partager son manteau
avec un mendiant grelottant de froid.
Martin est un soldat
romain du IIIᵉ siècle.
Son père était né en Hongrie,
mais son père était un officier romain.
Martin a vu Dieu
et s'est converti.
Il est devenu chrétien
et il refusait d'aller dans l'armée.
Il a dû être dans l'armée
parce que son père l'y obligeait.
C'était quelqu'un de très généreux
qui donnait sa solde de soldat aux pauvres
et qui, on le sait un soir à Amiens,
voit un pauvre hère dans la rue,
tout grelottant,
et va couper son manteau en deux,
sa cape en deux,
pour en donner une partie à ce garçon
afin qu'il puisse se réchauffer.
Sa cape sera conservée
après sa mort dans une pièce
qui prendra
le nom de capella, chapelle.
Ce soldat était devenu entre temps
moine, puis évêque de Tours de 372 à 397
sous le nom de Martin
et le mendiant était devenu
pour l'imaginaire populaire le Christ.
Martin va consacrer
sa vie aux plus démunis.
Détaché des choses
matérielles des villes,
il évangélise la vallée de la Loire
en créant des communautés monastiques
qui vont permettre
non seulement au christianisme
de se propager dans les campagnes,
mais aussi de s'y implanter durablement
en établissant
les premières paroisses rurales.
Tous les habitants
des campagnes et des bourgs assisteront
à ses funérailles en 397.
Quand il va mourir, Martin,
on va l'enterrer, c'est en novembre.
Et allez savoir pourquoi,
mais au moment de son enterrement,
le temps s'était mis
véritablement au beau.
Il faisait aussi beau qu'en été.
C'est de là que vient
l'expression l'été de la Saint-Martin.
De même qu'un jour, Martin prêche
et dit , "Voyez-vous ces oiseaux,
qui prennent
du poisson à plein bec ?
Ils sont comme les démons
qui prendront les âmes de ceux
qui ne sont pas convertis."
Et ces oiseaux sont devenus
des martins-pêcheurs.
Le sanctuaire
sur son tombeau devient après 460,
le principal relais
de la diffusion du christianisme
dans la Gaule du Nord.
L'Église parle
au peuple, elle nourrit les pauvres
et pousse au respect de la personne
humaine que l'Antiquité ignorait.
À Paris lors du
raid d'Attila en 451,
une jeune femme
de 28 ans, Geneviève,
issue d'une famille
romanisée d'origine franque,
s'appuie sur sa seule foi
afin d'organiser la défense de la ville
et détourne Attila de Paris.
Geneviève est une petite paysanne
qui vit dans ce qui est encore Lutèce
pratiquement, qui va devenir
Paris avant de devenir la capitale
et elle apprend que,
un peu comme Jeanne d'Arc,
elle a des voix, que les troupes
d'Attila, les turco mongols d'Attila,
les Huns vont envahir Paris.
Alors,
elle va soulever la population.
Elle va dire, il faut prier,
il faut se montrer sur les murailles,
il faut prier Dieu
et Dieu nous protégera.
Attila voyant cela, il hésite, un peu
comme il avait hésité
autrefois devant Constantinople.
Il dit, "est-ce que je prends Paris,
est-ce que je ne prends pas Paris ?"
Il décide de laisser Paris
au large et de descendre vers Orléans,
qui est beaucoup plus importante que Paris
à cette époque-là et beaucoup plus riche.
Car Paris n'est
encore qu'un grand village.
C'est un peu légendaire
cette histoire de Paris, ville superbe
qu'Attila n'a pas voulu envahir,
mais sainte Geneviève qui va
comme on le sait, devenir sainte.
Cette petite native de Nanterre,
sainte Geneviève va faire en sorte
que l'image de Paris dans l'histoire
s'incruste bien et que Paris
devienne la capitale du Royaume.
Les premières communautés de chrétiens
ont constitué des évêchés dans les villes.
Des groupes d'édifices s'érigent,
comprenant plusieurs basiliques,
le baptistère, le palais épiscopal.
La hiérarchie ecclésiastique est calquée
sur celle de l'administration civile.
Les évêques d'une même
province sont sous l'autorité
d'un évêque métropolitain
qui lui-même, reconnaît la primauté
de l'évêque de Rome.
Les réseaux sont
les mêmes, les hommes aussi.
Rémi est un aristocrate gallo-romain,
issu d'une famille de sénateurs.
En 459, il est promu à 22 ans
au siège métropolitain de Reims.
Sous son impulsion,
à partir de 480, en Gaule du Nord,
il y a des évêques
dans presque tous les chefs-lieux de cité.
Ces réseaux, les barbares doivent
en tenir compte, eux qui représentent
dorénavant l'État en Gaule.
Revenons sur la signification
du geste de Soissons.
À la loi de la guerre, Clovis,
le barbare païen, avait préféré la requête
d'un représentant de l'Église.
Le destin était tout tracé
ou la stratégie bien en place.
Clovis va asseoir son pouvoir
sur le ralliement des évêques.
Il semble avoir compris
que celui qui veut détenir
la puissance publique doit s'appuyer
sur l'autorité morale des évêques.
Il a alors 20 ans.
En cela, il a dû être
bien aidé par l'évêque de Reims.
Dans une lettre,
Rémi lui conseille de gouverner
avec le Conseil des évêques.
La population s'évangélise
grâce aux soldats du Christ
dont le patron est saint Martin.
À ce peuple tout neuf,
gallo-romain et chrétien, manquait un roi.
La proximité géographique va permettre
de lier les destins de Rémi et de Clovis,
ainsi que les destins
de l'Église catholique romaine
et de la nation française.
Le roi Clovis est
un homme vraiment très important
dans l'histoire de France,
c'est lui qui est à l'origine du royaume.
C'est vrai qu'on le voit
souvent comme l'homme de la rupture
entre l'Antiquité, l'empire romain
et le royaume
de France, le Moyen Âge.
En réalité, on s'aperçoit
que si Clovis a été accepté
et admis comme roi
par les anciens gallo-romains
et notamment par l'élite, par le clergé
et aussi la noblesse sénatoriale
gallo-romaine,
c'est justement parce qu'il a voulu
s'inscrire dans la continuité
de la civilisation romaine
et aussi en tant
que défenseur de la foi chrétienne,
de la religion chrétienne
pratiquée par les Romains.
Clovis va s'appuyer
sur les valeurs de son peuple de guerriers
et sur les valeurs romaines avec
le triomphe populaire du christianisme.
Les deux systèmes
de valeurs vont être d'autant
plus facilement conciliables
qu'à la bataille de Tolbiac,
une fois le vœu de conversion
prononcé par Clovis en cas de victoire,
les Alamans subissent une sévère déroute.
Lors de la fameuse bataille
de Tolbiac, alors qu'il est en péril,
il implore le dieu de Clotilde.
Il dit "Oh Dieu de Clotilde,
si jamais j'emporte cette bataille,
je vous jure
de me convertir et de me faire baptiser.
Dieu a voulu
que Tolbiac soit une victoire
pour Clovis qui s'est fait baptiser.
Si le vase de Soissons symbolise
la synthèse entre le monde germain
et le monde romain
qu'est en train d'établir Clovis,
le baptême de Reims la concrétise.
Il fallut
tout d'abord vaincre un dilemme.
Clovis devait renoncer
à la religion de ses ancêtres
et surtout à ce lien
qui l'unissait à son peuple.
Mais depuis 493,
l'influence de Clotilde commençait
à porter ses fruits.
Il partageait la même
fascination pour la culture romaine
et il venait
du même monde, le monde barbare.
Tandis que Clovis avait uniquement
assimilé l'héritage politique
de l'Empire romain, Clotilde
avait assimilé l'héritage de l'Empire
depuis Constantin,
celui des valeurs chrétiennes.
La bataille de Tolbiac,
après trois ans de fiançailles,
scella la véritable union entre eux.
À la fin des années 490,
Clovis épouse Clotilde,
princesse burgonde.
Cette princesse est catholique,
et on sait
qu'elle va mener une série d'initiatives
pour convertir
son mari à sa propre foi,
celle du concile de Nicée,
qu'on appelle le catholicisme.
Clovis, bien que lui,
étant toujours païen, avait décidé
de défendre
la religion chrétienne de l'Empire romain.
Je pense qu'il avait beaucoup
d'admiration pour cette culture romaine.
Il avait reçu
une éducation vraiment digne
de l'Empire romain, d'un roi romain,
puisque sa famille
et lui-même faisaient partie
de la hiérarchie
de l'Empire romain qui régnait en Gaule.
Après la sphère
du privé, il fallut s'occuper
de la sphère du public.
Ce fut le rôle de Rémi, un rôle politique
tout autant que spirituel.
À partir de 496,
commença le catéchisme,
même si le secret fut
bien gardé afin de ne pas effrayer
les guerriers francs.
Le secret resta
bien gardé jusqu'aux vœux publics
formulés à l'occasion
d'un pèlerinage à Saint-Martin de Tours.
Dans le sanctuaire de Martin,
Clovis prit le destin
de ce peuple entre ses mains.
La prochaine étape serait Reims.
Nous sommes
le jour de Noël 498 ou 499.
Tous les évêques
de la Gaule sont conviés autour de Rémi.
La marche solennelle
de Clovis vers le baptistère
pour s'y faire guérir
de la vieille lèpre qui le souillait,
doit être accompagnée de chants.
Puis, tandis
que Clovis s'arrête devant Rémi,
le saint homme l'exhorte, "depone colla,
Sicamber, dépose tes colliers, Sicambre".
Le terme "Sicambre" fait
référence à une tribu franque.
Quant au terme collier,
il désigne les amulettes
auxquelles les peuples germains
prêtaient des pouvoirs magiques.
Clovis se fait baptiser
par l'évêque Rémi qui lui dit,
on connaît la phrase merveilleuse
"Courbe-toi, fier Sicambre"
car Clovis faisait partie
de la tribu des Sicambres.
"Courbe-toi, fier Sicambre,
adore ce que tu as brûlé et brûle
ce que tu as adoré".
Après quoi,
il put être baptisé au nom du Père,
du Fils et du Saint-Esprit,
et oint du chrême sacré
avec le signe de la croix du Christ
sur sa tête qui allait rester chevelue.
Qu'importe, la couronne que portait
Clovis depuis 481 allait devenir sacrée,
comme le chrême
dont il venait d'être enduit.
Le chrême est
un mélange d'huiles et de baumes
qui est utilisé pour certains
sacrements, notamment le baptême.
La foule était tellement nombreuse
à se presser autour du baptistère
que le clerc qui portait
le chrême ne put lui-même y accéder.
Quand le roi se présenta
devant Rémi, celui-ci, dépourvu
de saint chrême, se mit à prier.
Une colombe fit alors
son apparition au-dessus
de la cuve baptismale et le baptistère
se remplit d'une odeur merveilleuse,
une odeur de sainteté.
La colombe tenait une ampoule dans son bec
qu'elle glissa entre les mains du pontife.
Les quatre évangélistes évoquent
lors du baptême du Christ,
la présence de l'Esprit Saint
sous la forme d'une colombe.
La première trace
écrite du récit du baptême de Clovis
avec La Colombe
et la Sainte Ampoule, date de 878.
Hincmar, alors archevêque
de Reims, tenta de légitimer
la primauté de son Église,
seule compétente à officier
lors du sacre
du roi des Francs.
Le saint chrême
qui a été oint sur la tête de Clovis,
descendait du ciel
et a été conservé à Reims.
Seul l'archevêque de Reims, en possession
de la sainte huile miraculeuse,
est autorisé à sacrer les rois des Francs,
successeurs de Clovis.
Reims a eu une importance
considérable à partir de ce moment-là,
car depuis Louis VI jusqu'à Charles X,
c'est-à-dire bien après la Révolution
et l'Empire,
les rois se feront baptiser
et surtout sacrer
dans la cathédrale de Reims,
sauf Henri IV, parce que c'était
la guerre civile, les guerres de religion.
Henri IV a été sacré couronné
dans la cathédrale de Chartres.
Le lien qui unit Clovis à Remi
et le lien qui unit la royauté française
à l'Église catholique
et qui en fait même la fille aînée
de l'Église, Clovis
étant le premier roi chrétien.
Le baptême de Clovis eut
des conséquences à long terme,
mais aussi les conséquences
immédiates et déjà retentissantes,
à commencer par ses
3000 guerriers francs qui reçurent
aussi le baptême,
en ce jour de Noël.
Que le geste de Clovis
ait été sincère ou politique,
les élites romaines vont
se rallier à lui et avec elles
l'ensemble de la population gauloise.
L'élan missionnaire
et la supériorité théologique
du clergé catholique,
expliquent en définitive
l'extinction
de l'hérésie arienne, en partie seulement.
Restait à prouver
l'hérésie par les armes.
Dieu allait choisir son camp.
Clovis en fit une mission qui concordait
parfaitement avec son ambition.
Au Sud-Est,
deux frères se partageaient
le royaume burgonde.
Les deux oncles de Clotilde,
Godegisèle et Gondebaud.
Les Burgondes sont
des envahisseurs venus de l'Est,
également de Germanie,
qui vont de leur côté,
régner sur le Sud-Est de la France
et même également sur la Suisse
qui deviendra
la Suisse romande et laisseront leur nom
à ce qui va devenir
le royaume de Bourgogne.
C'est un peuple
qui est extrêmement romanisé,
qui produit du droit
d'inspiration romaine et dont la capitale,
Lyon, ressemble
beaucoup à une capitale impériale
tel qu'on le connaissait
au IVᵉ siècle de notre ère.
Le premier fit appel
à Clovis afin d'établir
l'unité du royaume
au détriment du second.
Vainqueur à Dijon vers l'an 500,
Clovis poursuivit
Gondebaud jusqu'à Avignon.
Aux portes de la ville,
Clovis leva le siège moyennant
la promesse d'un tribut annuel.
Non seulement
Gondebaud renia sa parole,
mais il alla jusqu'à
se débarrasser de Godegisèle
et fit l'unité
du royaume burgonde à son profit.
Clovis ne bougea pas.
Il est vrai que Gondebaud,
lui aussi, sut s'appuyer sur les évêques
et les Gallo-romains
par l'intermédiaire
de son œuvre législative.
Il institua en Bourgogne des lois douces
pour qu'on n'opprime plus les Romains.
De plus, on disait
que Sigismond, son fils, s'apprêtait
à abjurer l'arianisme.
C'est ainsi que Clovis consentit
au mariage de Thierry,
son fils aîné,
avec la fille de Sigismond.
Les Burgondes étant alliés
de Clovis, restait les Goths.
Le peuple Goths était apparu
vers le IIIᵉ siècle de notre ère
dans la région du Danube.
Ils sont passés pour partie en Occident
à partir du IVᵉ siècle de notre ère
et forment essentiellement
deux branches la branche wisigothique
qui s'installe
en Aquitaine et en Espagne,
et la branche austro-gothique, en Italie.
En 410, les Wisigoths furent les premiers
à piller Rome, la mythique capitale.
Ils s'installèrent par la suite
dans le Sud-Ouest de la Gaule
en 418, avec le statut de fédérés.
À partir de là,
ils étendirent leur domination
jusqu'à la Loire
et jusqu'à une grande partie
de la péninsule Ibérique,
établissant leur capitale à Toulouse.
En 476, ils ajoutent
la Provence à leur royaume.
Les Wisigoths, c'est une peuplade,
une tribu d'envahisseurs
venus de Germanie.
C'étaient les Goths de l'Ouest.
On les appelait aussi les Sages, car ils
étaient peut-être un peu moins barbares.
C'étaient les barbares
les plus civilisés.
Ils se tiennent tranquilles,
se contentant
de persécuter les catholiques
si l'on en croit la propagande
menée par l'Empire d'Orient.
L'Empire et ce qui reste de romanité
ne pardonnera jamais au peuple gothique.
Le sac de Rome
qui marque pour bien des historiographes
la fin de l'Antiquité.
Ainsi, pour les Gallo-romains
comme Grégoire de Tours,
les Wisigoths convertis à l'arianisme
sont avant tout des fanatiques.
Pour Clovis,
fasciné par le mythe impérial,
l'annexion du royaume wisigothique
était depuis longtemps une priorité.
Baptisé selon
la tradition catholique,
Clovis avait maintenant une deuxième
bonne raison de punir ces barbares ariens.
La situation était insupportable
pour Clovis et pour Anastase,
l'empereur d'Orient
qui lui apporta son soutien.
Anastase est
le contemporain de Clovis.
On sait que c'est
un empereur qui a cherché
à restaurer la Méditerranée romaine,
notamment en Orient,
en menant des conquêtes
aux dépens des Perses,
mais aussi en nouant
de nombreux contacts avec l'Occident
en Italie,
avec les Ostrogoths,
mais également avec Clovis.
Il semble qu'Anastase ait conféré
le titre de consul honoraire à Clovis.
Ce soutien était
d'autant plus indispensable
que le roi des Wisigoths,
Alaric, sentant le vent tourner,
soignait son image et sa popularité
en usant des mêmes moyens que Gondebaud.
Il fit rédiger un bréviaire,
un abrégé de la loi romaine.
Il trouve que,
comment dirais-je, le pays est géré
par des lois gallo-romaines
et il décide de réécrire tout ça
à l'avantage des Wisigoths.
Il fait un abrégé,
un bréviaire qu'il fait rédigé ailleurs
sur Adour de ce droit romain.
Mais qu'il tourne
à l'avantage de ces hommes.
On l'appellera le Bréviaire d'Alaric.
Puis en 506 à Agde,
il permit la tenue d'un concile
ouvert à tous les évêques
catholiques de son royaume.
Si le Wisigoth obtenait l'adhésion des
élites et de la population gallo-romaine,
la conquête
deviendrait plus difficile
et l'annexion moins légitime.
L'armée franque
qui se lança dans cette conquête
du Sud-Ouest de la Gaule,
était composée de contingents rhénans
commandés par Clodéric,
fils du roi Sigebert de Cologne
et de contingents burgondes
sous les ordres de Sigismond.
Clovis interdit
à ses hommes de piller la cité de Tours.
À Poitiers,
le pèlerinage se poursuivit
et Saint-Hilaire,
figure de proue de la lutte
contre l'arianisme au IVᵉ siècle,
envoya à partir de sa basilique
un signe de bénédiction à Clovis,
sous la forme d'une lumière
qui semblait voler vers lui.
La bataille eut lieu
dans la plaine de Vouillé,
à une vingtaine
de kilomètres au Nord-Ouest de Poitiers
au cours du printemps 507.
La défaite des Wisigoths fut totale.
Alaric fut tué
des propres mains de Clovis.
Son fils Amalaric se replia
sur ses domaines espagnols.
Clovis eu alors
le champ libre afin de conquérir
et de pacifier l'Aquitaine.
La conquête s'effectuant
en tenaille à Thierry et Sigismond,
les régions intérieures
Clermont, Rodez, Albi.
À Clovis, les plus prestigieuses
capitales, Angoulême,
dont les remparts s'effondrent
à la seule vue du chef de guerre.
Bordeaux et Toulouse,
enfin, la capitale.
Seule la Provence resta wisigothique.
Au départ de l'expédition,
Clovis était soutenu
par l'empereur d'Orient, Anastase.
À l'arrivée, il fut reconnu digne
de porter les insignes du consulat.
Revêtu d'une tunique pourpre,
acclamé aux cris de consul et d'Auguste,
il défila à cheval,
semant l'or et l'argent.
En 508, l'empereur
de Constantinople, qui était en fait
la seule autorité romaine
après la disparition de l'empereur romain
d'Occident,
accorde au roi Clovis
le titre de consul romain.
La qualification d'Auguste,
ce qui montre bien que le roi Clovis
s'inscrit dans la continuité
de l'Empire romain,
c'est-à-dire
que le royaume franc fait partie
en quelque sorte de la continuité
de l'Empire romain et n'est pas du tout
en rupture comme
on aurait pu l'imaginer.
Ce triomphe populaire eut lieu
en 508, à Tours, la cité de Saint-Martin.
Le monde civilisé se partageait alors,
entre l'Empire d'Orient et le royaume
que venait de constituer Clovis.
Clovis avait reçu
de son père un double héritage.
Roi des Francs
de Tournai, il était aussi chef
d'une armée fédérée
au service de Rome.
Être roi des Francs,
c'est avoir le droit de commander
et de punir ses hommes.
Être chef d'une armée fédérée,
c'est être non seulement
responsable des citoyens,
mais aussi maître d'un territoire.
Clovis intégra cette logique.
À partir de Soissons, il s'efforça
de s'approprier le revenu de l'impôt,
de tirer profit de la frappe
des monnaies et de mettre la main
sur les domaines du fisc,
de façon à y installer ses troupes.
Après le baptême
et les victoires, après l'évangélisation,
ce qui manquait
à Clovis pour asseoir sa légitimité
sur un monde gallo-romain,
c'était une loi
sous l'influence du droit romain.
Clovis se fit donc législateur.
Il étendit le Bréviaire d'Alaric
à l'ensemble des hommes libres.
Le bréviaire s'inspirait
d'un code rédigé en 438 qui compilait
toutes les constitutions impériales
depuis 312, depuis Constantin.
La nouveauté du code était
que si le souverain promulguait
bien les lois, il était aussi
le responsable de ses lois devant Dieu
et qu'il se devait de les respecter.
Il pouvait réclamer
en retour l'obéissance de tous.
Pourtant,
le sort des chefs rhénans,
ses alliés de toujours,
pouvait laisser perplexe.
Le roi Sigebert de Cologne
fut assassiné par son fils
sur les conseils de Clovis.
Clovis n'ayant plus qu'à exécuter
celui-ci pour avoir été parricide.
Ces meurtres se justifiaient
par une nécessaire mise en ordre.
Ce que le roi était
en train de fonder devait
se transmettre à ses héritiers.
D'ailleurs, Clovis
n'avait officiellement tué personne.
Il était primordial
de rétablir la paix.
Dans ce but,
Clovis compléta la loi salique.
La loi salique est un code juridique
qui a été promulgué sans doute
aux environs de l'an 500
et probablement sous l'autorité de Clovis.
C'est un code
essentiellement de droit privé
qui prévoit les amendes,
les peines qui sont infligées
pour toutes sortes de crimes,
mais qui ne précisent en aucun cas
les modes de succession entre francs.
Ainsi, la peine encourue
pour le meurtre d'un homme libre était
de 200 sous,
qu'il soit franc ou romain.
La loi tenta d'en finir
avec les interminables vendettas
et d'instaurer un État de droit.
La loi salique c'est la loi qui
doit son nom à la tribu des Francs,
qu'on appelle les Francs saliens.
En réalité, c'est tout simplement
une première constitution du royaume,
parce que c'est une loi
qui marque strictement les choses,
c'est-à-dire
qu'on interdit aux gens de se battre
et de s'entretuer à moins
de verser des amendes considérables
donc,
on évite à le faire.
Les femmes n'ont pas
le droit de commettre l'adultère,
sinon elles sont enterrées
dans la boue jusqu'au col,
Donc, elles évitent
de tromper leur mari.
Clovis accorda aussi beaucoup
d'importance à la christianisation
de ses lois,
interdisant les mariages incestueux
afin de rationaliser
les successions, notamment
celles du trône.
C'est une loi, une constitution,
la loi salique, qui est assez machiste.
Les femmes n'ont aucun
pouvoir, c'est-à-dire que foncièrement
elles ne peuvent hériter strictement
rien, aucun domaine, aucun bien
et cette affaire-là va
se reporter sur la couronne du royaume
puisque depuis
les Francs saliens jusqu'à Charles X,
aucune femme n'a régné,
n'a été reine de France
sauf en étant
la femme du roi, naturellement,
parce que la couronne ne pouvait pas
se transmettre de femme en femme.
Bréviaires et pactes furent soumis
à l'approbation d'un conseil de sages
composé de vieux
chefs militaires et d'évêques.
L'ensemble fut promulgué par le roi
qui n'y apporta aucune modification.
Les hommes du roi, les Francs
et les citoyens
de l'Empire, les Gallo-romains,
tous sont
dorénavant sujets de Clovis.
Avec la conquête de l'Aquitaine,
le centre de gravité
du royaume s'était déplacé vers le sud.
En 511, la France, si on veut
bien appeler ainsi le royaume franc,
est composée essentiellement
des territoires au nord de la Loire,
d'une annexion récente
en Aquitaine, de l'Auvergne
et de quelques petites possessions
dans la région provençale.
Clovis avait besoin
d'une nouvelle capitale.
Le choix de Paris s'appuyait
sur des critères caractéristiques
de la mutation
en train de s'opérer.
Paris, c'était tout d'abord
le choix de la cité de sainte Geneviève
qui avait résisté à Attila.
Clovis fit édifier
sur son tombeau une basilique
dédicacée aux saints apôtres Pierre
et Paul, pour en faire son mausolée
et celui de sa dynastie.
C'est la légitimité dynastique
que Clovis assurait à ses successeurs
en érigeant un mausolée qui en faisait
les protecteurs des apôtres.
Ensuite, Paris bénéficiait
d'une situation exceptionnelle.
Le site était insulaire
et remarquablement fortifié.
C'était un carrefour
économique et historique,
entre le Nord,
d'où étaient originaires les Francs
et le Sud, qui représentait
l'avenir avec la colonisation.
De Paris, Clovis convoqua à Orléans
en 511, le premier concile des Gaules.
En termes purement ecclésiastiques,
le concile a peu d'importance,
mais en termes national,
c'est la première réunion
de toutes les autorités
de l'Église dans le territoire
qu'on va bientôt
appeler la France.
32 évêques furent présents.
La moitié de ceux
qui officiaient à l'intérieur du royaume.
Un absent de marque, saint Rémi.
Une des décisions
du concile fut en effet de soumettre
à l'autorité royale la possibilité
pour un laïc de devenir clerc.
On comprend
les réticences du saint homme.
La liberté des églises était menacée,
mais les évêques réunis
à Orléans acceptèrent l'intrusion
et scellèrent le début
de la collaboration du roi et des évêques.
En effet, si le roi est
au-dessus des évêques,
c'est davantage
pour des raisons politiques.
On dit qu'il a
la responsabilité du pouvoir temporel,
celui lié
aux questions matérielles.
Par contre, l'autorité
des représentants de l'Église
fut reconnue sur le plan spirituel,
et celui-ci était intemporel.
Le partage du pouvoir évitait
le totalitarisme arien où le roi,
puisqu'il conservait
son statut de surhomme,
était aussi le chef de l'Eglise.
L'avenir était ailleurs
et Clovis sembla l'avoir compris.
Il envoya une couronne
à l'évêque de Rome, le temporel au roi,
le spirituel au pape.
C'est l'idée du Moyen Âge.
Avec l'insécurité,
les villes se sont enfermées
dans leur citadelle
et Paris en est un remarquable exemple.
Sur le plan social
et économique, le Moyen Âge se prépare.
L'esclavage commence
à disparaître grâce à la christianisation
de la législation.
Le servage s'annonce.
Se mettent alors
en place des seigneuries rurales.
La terre peut l'emporter sur la ville.
Un double processus de décomposition
et de recomposition sociale est à l'œuvre.
À partir d'un gouvernement
qui, au début du VIᵉ siècle,
reste avant tout
un commandement militaire,
Clovis s'élabore l'esquisse
d'un royaume qui pourrait s'appuyer
sur un gouvernement
centralisé, avec revenus et impôts
qui remontent à Paris.
Clovis mourut
d'une mort naturelle, le 27 novembre 511.
Il sera inhumé dans le mausolée
qu'il avait prévu à cet effet
et Clotilde
l'y rejoindra 34 ans plus tard.
La seule date dont on soit sûrs
dans l'histoire de Clovis,
c'est la date
de sa mort, le 27 novembre 511.
Il est mort à Paris
et il a été enterré à Paris,
dans l'église qui s'appelait
à l'époque des Saints Apôtres,
qui a ensuite été renommée
Église Sainte Geneviève,
mais qui malheureusement
n'existe plus aujourd'hui.
Les bâtiments ont été démolis
au début du XIXᵉ siècle.
Quelques fouilles ont été faites
à cette époque-là.
On n'a jamais retrouvé
le tombeau de Clovis.
Peut-être est-il encore aujourd'hui
sous le goudron de la rue Clovis.
Il faudrait faire des recherches
pour voir si on pourrait le retrouver.
Au XIVᵉ siècle,
l'imagerie de Clovis refit surface
par le biais
d'un symbole, les trois fleurs de lys,
évoquant une trinité virginale
qui allait orner les armoiries royales.
La fleur de lys est
ce que l'on appelle
un meuble héraldique,
c'est-à-dire un symbole qui se met sur,
sur les blasons,
sur les étendards.
Cette jolie petite fleur qui avait
déjà été utilisée sous les Carolingiens.
Mais c'est à partir des Capétiens,
et notamment avec Louis VII,
qu'elle figure
officiellement partout sur champ d'azur
pour signaler
que cette fleur de lys, c'est la monarchie
c'est la royauté française.
La légende raconte qu'à la veille
de la bataille de Tolbiac en 496,
un ermite qui avait reçu
la visite d'un ange conseilla Clotilde,
la femme de Clovis,
de remplacer les trois crapauds
qui ornaient les boucliers des guerriers
francs par trois fleurs de lys.
C'est ainsi que
dans le contexte de la guerre de 100 Ans,
huit siècles plus tard,
il était important de faire remonter
l'origine du pouvoir temporel
du roi de France à Clovis
pour combattre
le nouvel hérétique anglais.
Chlodevechus,
Crotechildis, Chlotachurius,
Chlodoveus,
Ludovicus, Clovis.
La diversité des appellations
témoigne d'un monde en pleine mutation
dont Clovis a été
le principal artisan de son vivant
et encore
davantage après sa mort.
Charlemagne en donnant
à son fils le nom de Ludovic,
plus connu sous
le nom français de Louis,
Proche du nom
francique Ludwig, de Clovis,
mesurait bien l'importance
de la légitimité originelle
de l'illustre chef de guerre.
Après Louis Iᵉʳ le Pieux,
16 autres monarques porteront
le nom de Clovis.
Le monde de Clovis,
c'est tout d'abord la fin d'un monde,
celui de l'Empire romain.
C'est surtout le début
d'une longue gestation
qui prend fin
avec les Carolingiens
et qui sera suivie d'une longue
maturation avec les Capétiens.
L'esquisse de ce que sera
ce monde pendant près de 1300 ans.
Clovis, c'est l'union entre la royauté
et l'Église à l'intérieur d'un territoire
qui va continuer à s'agrandir
et qui ne s'appelle pas encore France.
Clovis pourra dorénavant
s'appuyer sur cette union
et tous ses successeurs
sur le trône de France suivront
ou devront suivre cet exemple.
Clovis incarne aussi
les valeurs de la nation française
et celle de la République,
pour l'historien Fustel de Coulanges,
en 1888.
On était réputé franc
parce qu'on obéissait
à celui
qui s'appelait roi des Francs,
parce qu'on lui payait
l'impôt et qu'on combattait pour lui,
parce qu'on recevait de lui
des faveurs, des grades, des fonctions
sans distinction de race.
Pour les historiens contemporains,
il est même précurseur de l'Europe
telle qu'on la conçoit aujourd'hui,
une synthèse
entre Germains et Latins,
une connexion
entre la mer du Nord
et la mer Méditerranée.